[Music]
what's up guys I'm gonna be showing you
a video today on how to make money from
farming so we're gonna be doing we're
gonna be doing herb runs okay and so the
herb I'm going to use today is toadflax
so you only need 38 farming it's very
easy to get and so I'm just to start the
video I'm gonna go ahead and show you
how much they cost so the toad flax
seeds
we're just instant buy them buy five of
them and then you need super compost so
buy five of those
all right so now that you have your
super compost and your five toe flex
seeds and your five super compost this
works for other herbs too but sometimes
the profit isn't as good so I'm just
gonna show you these so what you're
gonna want to have on a normal run is a
stamina potion a rake a shovel or Spade
so i-5 of your herb seeds seed dipper
five compost slaughterin an ecto file if
you have one errands and a nursery so to
start off we're gonna go ahead and
teleport oh you also need sorry you need
a amulet of glory so you need a way to
get to drain are you need magic
secateurs which is from the fairy tale
part one quiz these aren't mandatory but
I just recommend them because you get
like a better chance of getting more
herbs or something like that and then
combat bracelet to go to the ranging
guild and then yeah so we're gonna go
ahead and go to the range guild
so just run down here there's a patch
down here
all right and sometimes your herbs will
be dead when you show up so you'll just
have to take them out but with the super
compost I think you're guaranteed five
but you can get up to like fourteen so I
got seven
so use your super compost on the patch
that's now empty and then use your seeds
on it so once you're done with your
herbs I choose to clean them because I
think they sell for more and I have one
third herb lurex experience you just use
them on the leprechaun they'll be a
leprechaun in age farming spot and he'll
note them for you which is really
helpful so next I go to the I use my
echo file I think you have to do the
ghost of holy quest for this in the
description I'll leave all the
requirements for the teleports I use but
off the top my head I'm not quite sure
so this is another herb spot these
didn't die either
seven eight okay so I ate this time so I
gotta get more
so use your super compost on the empty
spot then use your seed then run over to
the leprechaun and poops you'll know
them so the next spot you don't want to
go to drain are oh and by the way okay
so I think you need 25 construction like
I said I'll leave this in the
description 25 construction to movie
house to zaiah because that's where my
home is that's the easiest way I think
to get to that spot because there is a
her patch in Isaiah so like I said in
the description I'll leave a
requirements list but I'm just trying to
show you guys how easy it is to make
money just doing her browns you mean
yeah with such low farming especially so
just pick them see I'm when I can get
come on fourteen can I get fourteen five
six seven eight
come on fourteen nine oh wow see I'm
just getting one more each time that's
cool
boom I don't get this vide but a lot of
times you will get a lot easier compost
on your super compost and then even ours
on him the next tough part I'm gonna go
ahead and use I'm gonna go to Camelot
remember you have your stamina potion in
case you don't want to read on run the
energy you run over here I just spot
right above Catherine II know dead hurts
again that so go ahead and pick these
herbs
come on fourteen you get fourteen three
four five
six five six all right uh so that though
use your compost on it and it needs your
sheep and then we're gonna go ahead and
teleport to our house eighties a like I
said I thinking you 25 construction and
I think it's like 9 K or something 8500
something like that actually messed up
my house was still in taverley so you
I'm in falador and you just go talk to
this house guy it's really easy to find
click the first option move my house
please or would you like to move to so
it's current I'm just in say and then
it's 8.5 K and then now my house / there
so now I can tell about there
right over here there's a nerve spot I
believe this is our final one yep it is
so Wow okay so all of them were not dead
so I am depending on your farming level
I believe it's off of that sometimes
they'll die sometimes they want but when
they don't you make a lot more profit
obviously so just five there you per
compost on it then use your seed and
then I'm going to tell participant
exchange so I can show you guys how much
I made so your
so they sold for 101 K and so we're
going to add up so we're gonna do the
101 5 3 5 - the 3310 of the super
compost - the 1956 of the seat so 96k in
about 5 minutes so we'll do 60 divided
by 5 convince my mother 5 minutes is 12
so 12 let's just say 96 k so that's
about a mil if you could do it in hours
so you can do this it takes five minutes
to do and you can do herb runs it takes
eighty minutes for all the patches to
grow all the way so if you do this twice
a day I mean 200 K you can get a bond
within a few days so yeah so that's my
video guys I hope that helped you and
stay tuned for my next video